こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん人前に立って話したのかありますかぼってもあのは
結構そのイベントとか人前で話すことがあるんですけども
原稿その関係の皆様の橋上とはリアクションすごい大事だと思うんですよ
いやそんななんかめちゃくちゃでかい舞台話じゃないです例えば学校の名が文化祭の
出し物とか
始業式卒業式運動会と合唱コングル1
前で立って何か言わなきゃいけないときもあると思います絶対社会人もそうです1枚の
プレゼントカーなら話す機会が絶対あると思うんですよユーチューバーもしっかりそう
いう機会がありますイベントとか今日的にそういう小規模のターン敵がいる戻って観客
のリアクション次第ではしゃべったりするのがめちゃくちゃ気持ちよくなると思うん
ですよ
ただですがめっちゃもないかといって大爆笑すると気持ちいいと思うんですよね
てい
[音楽]
金玉
気持ちいいんですよもう何じゃ何言っても笑われるとか何言ってもいいで約村帰って
くるっていう状況を作り出せば人前に立ったり大勢のする前でしゃべることもすぐに
気持ちよくなればもう
しゃべりてる女じゃない受け手側の問題にしちゃいま消滅理不尽なこと言ってますけど
それだけでも何が起こっても自分の好きなようなリアクションをとって来る観客を作る
には自分
人で観客になればいいんじゃないかという事で私長い時間をかけて観客席全員俺にして
みました
奈良でも反逆的なにというかわかんないでしょまぁ実際見れば分かりますの観客での僕
ですなのでもう面白いこと言えば絶対払ってくれるし悲しい事言えば絶対泣いてくれる
もう僕の思うがままに観客の皆さんのリアクションをとってくれるという状況の動画を
作ってみたのでこれを見て是非
人の話を聞く側の人間はリアクションを取ること大事なんだ
なんと思って見ていただけると嬉しいですでは以下を作るの超大変だったって
4日
はい所長
丼の大きさでも
大変なことにヤバイそのことが分かっている
十分ん
んん
a
皆さんこんばんは
ドクター始めです
今日のトークショーは
世界家つまらない一生
教えたり割れて言っても
わかればとん
題名の調理その前だっていくと思うんですけれども
布団がふと the
[笑い]
同じ位置は塗っていきたいとおもいます
時間を作っ
実は私実は私3
日前に
イチョウのところがちょっと痛くなって
点滴を打ちにいきましたふーっ
はい月
ああああっ
[拍手]
地球にリーダーになることもないんですけどもう今はけっこうよくなったかなって思う
んですよね私
まったく今は問題ないですか
あっは2はですよね驚かしてすいません
全然あの申し上げないです本当に紡績ないと心からと思っていますすいませんすいませ
んでした
なんで描いたになったかというと僕棒は簡単んですけど多分ポテトチップスの食べ過ぎ
が原因かなとか思いつつも
そんなことも大ふっとしたらずっとですまずは可能
いろんな要因があって家が2袋毛穴が開いちゃったりたい一つの
悪くなってるらしいんであん一眼やで外悲哀んですけど車
広がってかつが悪くてその中こういう家とドカ雪という不満じゃん旅先でいると
おっしゃってんじゃないでしょって感じでもある
そうかどうかはわからないんですけどまぁ現実的な問題としては実際にはの胃袋すごい
痛くてなんか
出ちゃうよね出ちゃうんですけれどもどうしようもなくて頭も良い
ていただいたという感じでございます
ああああああ
みんなで前じゃないよ
右手じゃないよ
小そう言ってんだよ今ではー
皆さん皆さんいいですかこの章世界つまらないし長男ですねそれを分かってきている
はずだ今日は
分かっているのにネイル坪野そのソース web
俺はどういう表情も小生は分からないんだよなぁみんなに住んだとされるぞ
だからなくなるとお前ら俺まで嬉しくなっちゃうだろうさあ
やめてくれただそうまでして
最後は
ん笑顔で悪ですね
そういうことでパワーは分バザーを驚かせませんって皆から
デーモンこれだけ覚えて帰っていただきたいです今日は人生にサプライズを時は必須
です
[音楽]
ああああああ
c 言語グリーン
[拍手]
あっは
[音楽]
bl